[Musique]
les séries je suis très très chaud ce
soir je me sens bien dans mon corps je
suis heureux de vous voir les cherry est
ce que vous avez remarqué qu'on n'a pas
un truc que je kiffe grave
ils m'ont enlevé ses cubes si tu me
pourrissent est là derrière il ya je
peux danser
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
mais ouais c'est qu'il est en dehors du
monde là-dedans c'est petit à petit ses
pantalons que je te va
[Applaudissements]
je pense à tout moment ce soir je suis
très choquée c'est les pendant le prime
j'ai trouvé hier soir deux heures du
matin muni d un éclair de génie mais
attends pas ma porte
2h du mat oui qui s'est vu l'apport des
génies d'adieu du paf piscine lynch et
tu as tu pas le lieu du parc déguisé en
haricot macias est ce qui est venue d'un
ton chéri mon chéri ouais c'est en train
avec hommage à sève nicolas sarkozy un
dieu du parc vous trouvez à mon ciré je
voulais dire demain pour le prince
pourquoi tu mettrais pas un micro et
toutes les personnes qui veulent chanter
elles veulent vient de chantier
directement c'est à dire même le patron
de la chaîne un an de marcheurs
déception
[Applaudissements]
les particules de viol
et pas une chaise qui va m'empêcher dans
ce qui est classique comme ça les
échalotes débat des noms qui est agile
comme moi les a laissé jouer noté allait
finalement les enquêtes agi comme ça
personne
je suis très beau dans le dossier j'ai
fait pas chez les parents la plume on
sont pas manchots est bloqué par la
chaîne avait parlé comme ça
[Applaudissements]
voilà
igor jdanov à la table scolaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]